pays attend aussi toujours des
livraisons d'armes lourdes des Européens
les 27 toujours incapables de répondre à
cette demande Berlin hésitante encore à
donner à son feu vert depuis dimanche le
gouvernement allemand a enchaîné les
propos contradictoires concernant ses
chars léopard la coalition au pouvoir
étant très divisé sur le sujet les
explications de notre correspondante
admire ces derniers jours ont clairement
mis en évidence les tensions qui agitent
la coalition tripartite menée par le
chancelier social-démocrate Olaf Scholt
sanction qui se cristallise bien sûr
autour de la livraison de ses chars de
combat à l'Ukraine alors pour faire
simple il y a d'un côté les partenaires
minoritaires du gouvernement les
libéraux et les écologistes qui sont
clairement favorables à la livraison de
ces chars et qui ne s'en cache pas à
l'image de la ministre des Affaires
étrangères l'écologie
qui a assuré dimanche que Berlin ne
s'opposerait pas à Varsovie si le
gouvernement polonais choisissait
d'envoyer de tels engins en Ukraine et
puis il y a de l'autre côté le
chancelier ola Scholtz qui n'a pas
confirmé les déclarations d'années
d'Anna Léna berbock hier et qui n'a
toujours pas pris de décision car son
parti le Parti social-démocrate lui est
très partagé très hésitant la plupart
des sociaux-démocrates ne veulent pas
endosser seul la responsabilité
d'envoyer des chars d'assaut à l'Ukraine
en tout cas pas sans la protection des
États-Unis la crainte d'être considéré
par la Russie comme un état
cobelligérant et omniprésente et c'est
une crainte qui est partagée par de
nombreux Allemands